[MUSIC]
So we had very diverse
topics presented here, and
I don't know what I am going to
do with the panel but [LAUGH].
Now one thing I want
I was thinking about
when you say yeah your general
technology for healthcare.
There is of course
the blue sky thing.
You start personalized medicine,
or wonder materials, or
whatever that helps healthcare.
This is for first world or
beyond first world also.
How to make things more
effective in the current system?
Now how do you have better data
tracking for healthcare, or
better robots, or whatever?
And third of course is
the real social angle where
things that are people who are
not served by current methods
very well, I mean especially in
India you would see them and I
can see some of you you are from
USA you've been studying India.
So one common theme in many
of these were the community
aspect or having peers,
understanding the community,
understanding the peers, the
peer relationship, et cetera.
Which is a challenge in India
by itself, because the, and
especially if you are looking
at the under served rural and
the world population.
The finding that who
was influential and
how influence spreads.
There are all kinds of angles.
There's gender angles,
that economic class angle,
there is Maybe caste angle and
what,
actually I was
intrigued by question.
This is also a lot of free
advice which are contradictory,
given out by everybody in
the society, you know.
These medicines are not good,
English medicines are bad.
These medicines are good,
and so on.
So there is a whole
lot of phenomena.
How do we understand
these things?
And any suggestions on that?
Any comments on that?
These are the kind of
things I wanted to, and
especially it's been proven.
You also said that, you know,
the intervention at the right
level like maternal health or
getting the women to understand
things has a bigger impact
on everywhere it's proven if
you have women literacy affects
the overall literacy because
the mother is literate,
the children will
definitely be literate.
So some people
are more important, so
how do you understand these
dynamics within the Indian
context a little bit more, which
may be different from others.
If some of you have
some comments on that?
Because you have been
doing this in India?
>> Okay.
So yeah in the IFV model
that I just talked about,
so we are being a network of
hospitals, medical service
providers in the geographies
that you are working in.
And one of the ways we are doing
that, so we have listed all of
the hospitals, and all of the
shops that we are working on,
and all of the medical shops,
pharmacy shops, and so
every time a member goes
to one of these shops,
we get feedback
from that member.
How was the shop,
how was the experience?
What do you recommend
with someone else, and
based on that there's
a continuous feedback and
rating mechanism that builds up.
And then we have mechanism for
blacklisting someone,
we have mechanisms of,
prioritizing where to go.
So this is how we are building
a trusted source of,
pool of health providers.
>> How build a social network
that is more relevant, say,
in an environment like India.
>> I think one of the things
that's really important that you
mentioned was to incorporate
the cultural and on the ground
demographics, which we try to do
in our model of TB epidemiology.
And so that was partially just
getting the demographics right.
Getting the connection between
people and getting real data.
But also to realize that
a lot of the human behavior
would influence the success
of the program.
And we try to incorporate that
into our model by looking at
the different, for instance,
the different treatment
patterns that people had.
So we really struggled with how
to model versus pilot clinics as
opposed to government sponsored
clinics, because there's
much less oversight, and it's
hard to track people as they go
around to different types
of private TB clinics.
And that was something that we
definitely took into account
just in India, not for other
types of TB modeling in other
countries, so it's very context
specific in that sense.
>> So I come from
design department, and
I'm very major advocate of the
design processes that we follow,
specifically in the context
where we don't really know who
our users are, right?
So we have this method called
participatory design or
human-centered design where it's
not just about understanding
what are the problems that users
have, but what are the typical
behavior in terms of
socio-cultural behavior or
technological behavior
that a users would have.
And then designing solutions
accordingly, which generally we
have seen that finding a lot
sort of acceptance among users,
because you know that if the
users do not really know how to
use a mobile phone or
even a feature phone.
So in such kind of context,
does a mobile application
make any sense?
So then how do we
really incorporate such
technologies and
behavioral aspect of the users
into your final solution that
eventually it is accepted and
finally it creates an impact.
Something that given that
we have a technology cloud,
core technology
cloud I'm certainly
mentioning that
the participatory design or
human centered design has
a huge impact on how.
Instead of what my
opinion is and instead
of conducting an evaluation and
seeing whether it works or
not, a prior process of
understanding the users and
designing according to them is
something that has been proven
[INAUDIBLE].
>> So going back to your
question about how do you
design social networks that are
more context specific to India,
I would say that I mean cultural
norms dictate I mean so
influence spread models that
would work well in America may
or may not work well here.
I mean one thing that I can
think of right off the top of my
head is that in India,
neighborhoods are very
important.
When you face trouble, you go to
your neighbors and you ask them
for help, and so therefore
Those edges [INAUDIBLE],
I mean if you think about them
as edges in a social network,
those edges would motivate.
I mean it's more likely that
you will be influenced by your
neighbor on a daily basis as
opposed to somebody else that
might be.
So these kind of
context-specific things can be
utilized.
They can make the models
more context-specific,
more elaborate.
Yeah, they can definitely
play a role in sort of making
the influence spread much more
effective in an Indian context
or in any context.
Yeah.
>> So we should be employing
more Indian sociologists to
understand the,
I mean people who study
specifically the especially I
mean you are probably still
talking about the urban model.
The rural is probably
even very different.
>> Definitely yeah.
>> So even one of the startups
which recently had,
this is a simple startup a Uber.
Uber for minibuses, for
commute in Hyderabad.
This thing also called commute,
and one of the findings
they realized that bulk of the
passengers who use it are women,
because the public transport
safety issues are far more
important for women than for
men in any city.
So this is an unintended
discovery with this,
a wise discovery.
>> Yep.
>> So if you have another
question of what this thing is,
if you have a limited
amount of material.
Thousands of problems in places
like India or many countries
like India, if you have
a limited resource which we all
have How do we increase
the awareness and access?
I mean, when you are healthy
there is more productivity for
the county, for everybody.
So what is the best way
to give the resources for
awareness printing,
a very common thing?
To me,
this would be a high priority,
because if people get
aware they take action.
>> So you are saying how
should we spread awareness?
>> Yes, how you spread
awareness, but what's the mix of
say, spreading awareness
versus actual prevention? Right.
>> The preventive kind of step.
>> Okay, I think I mean, so
my point of view is that as,
it just spreading information on
a distributed sort of a level.
You tell people, and
then you tell people
that itself won't help.
There has to be government
impetus as well to I mean If
you want [INAUDIBLE] annotation,
so for example,
if you spread information
about you should be using to
all different regular basis, but
the government is not willing
enough [INAUDIBLE],
what do you do?
There has to be mix and
match, you know.
>> [INAUDIBLE] and awareness.
>> And
awareness spreading, yeah.
>> Somebody else has [INAUDIBLE]
>> Also, we
have to look at the difference
between awareness spreading and
reinforcement of behavior,
right?
In classic, there's sociological
theory which says that
simple contagion, which is
like awareness spreading, and
complex contagion, which is what
is needed to change behavior,
to actually cause prevention,
impact prevention.
You need different
kinds of resources or
different kinds of
network mechanism.
So If you just wanted
to spread awareness,
a diffusion model will work, but
if you want to change behavior
you would need to reinforce that
behavior through multiple
people or multiple networks.
So it cannot just be
the simple act of, hey,
I'm gonna talk to you about
maybe washing your hands,
you would have to have enough
people who are gonna role
model that behavior which would
lead to that complex contagion.
So you have to design your
interventions accordingly.
So I guess, in terms of
designing interventions you have
to keep that in mind.
>> Yeah, I think this is
something we can like in the HIV
work, right or invention.
Where we are thinking about
different models that influence
spread that they're sort of
passive, information just sort
of spreads like a virus
from one person to another.
This just like really isn't
a particularly accurate model in
these domains, when you want
people engaged you want them
thinking about these issues,
changing their behaviors.
And so, maybe just like trying
to get as many people to hear
something about, you know,
whatever information you're
spending just isn't really very
useful thing, in general, right?
So the mix really has to be
focused much more towards
things to get people
engaged in whatever.
Whatever sort of topic
that you're interested in.
>> So, yeah, I was going
to open it up to, you know,
cuz there's no point in taking
here itself, so please.
>> So, yeah, I was just it was
the last question actually got
me thinking, there is, of
course, a lot of experience with
trying to reduce smoking for
example in the US.
Are there lessons from that that
you can take changing people's
behavior or what was learned
from that, if anything?
>> Yes, so I think so I'm not
really familiar with that
literature in detail, but what
I've seen we can draw lessons
things like sort of
general guidelines.
Like, yes,
networks are important,
peer influence is very
important, that's sort
of been very well documented
[INAUDIBLE] public health topic.
And so, then I think that this
is something that's sort of
interesting.
That we have the potential
to do in these new domains,
where we sort of have
the collaboration,
right between the researchers
and the social scientists.
Because it makes us think of
sort of new questions to try and
measure, right?
To try to get sort of
more granular models of
influence spread, and
better understanding
of the underlying mechanisms
in ways that are helpful for
optimizing preventative
strategies.
And these are questions that
a lot of the time sort of,
like Eric were saying, like
either feel wouldn't think to
measure the right
things on their own.
And so, it's something that
we sort of have the potential
to get into now.
>> So, I'm also not
an expert in that area, but
I think that for smoking,
the message actually mattered.
So for years, right, people have
been saying that you shouldn't
be smoking, because it kills you
and it turns out no one cares,
because they are like, yeah, it
will kill me like in 60 years or
whatever.
And it turns out that if
the message had been careful if
you start smoking you're going
to be addicted forever and
it will be like
you're in a prison.
It would have been a lot
more impactful and
far fewer people would have
started actually smoking.
So I think this I don't
really know how to put it in
a different context right.
But I think that
the message really
like with the same
amount of effort,
a different message can make
a significant difference.
>> There's also issues about,
there really are normative
influence changes that will
attract very clearly within
populations, they just haven't
done very very large time scale.
It's not something
that happens like this,
especially with behavior
change and there was a lot of
structural interventions that
worked out laws that made it, so
that it was increasingly
expensive to smoke.
It was increasingly illegal
to smoke in particular areas.
All of which drove a lot of
social norms that made it, so
that smoking was now
perceived as as a bad thing.
And so, I think sort of the idea
of messages is a very slippery
thing in behavior change.
It's not always messages
that are important.
>> Okay, we get that and
[INAUDIBLE] is the only
product markets for sure.
>> Yeah, I think the shaming
worked in this case, right,
with tobacco, it's a stigma,
right, to smoke in the US.
And most people quit,
because their friends
will not approve of it. Yeah
>> So speaking of smoking, for
example, I feel more than social
network what is also important
is what the people who are like
the companies Phillip Morris.
It has exited out of you as it's
creating havoc in Indonesia,
because the government
there is not intervening.
So it's not a question
of network science,
it's the question of these big
entities are making big monies,
so that's where
the intervention has to come.
I think technology social
network is not important here,
the governments have to clamp,
Philip Morris has
to [LAUGH] yeah.
And the story of Phillip Morris
Indonesia and Australia that is
a really solid story and that
is causing the biggest impact on
how much people smoke-
>> It has to be a combination of
both, all right, you have to-
>> No, but what is happening in
Indonesia like six year olds
are addicted to smoking,
that is not, I mean that is
just some big company is making
huge amounts of money
>> Right.
>> And
they have to be throttled.
Their neck has to be held.
>> It's also socially acceptable
for a six-year old to smoke.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah, but
a lot of money is made by-
>> We have to also
make a comment about something
there, that it is acceptable.
>> Yeah.
>> No, it's not acceptable, but
it's just that once people get
addicted, then you don't care
whether it's acceptable or
not, you're just addicted.
>> Well, I guess it leads
to that in the first place,
right, if it's acceptable then
you're going to [INAUDIBLE]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGH]
>> Like for
example [INAUDIBLE] Are you
able to publish this work in
a medical journal, will the
doctors be able to see this and
look at this as the intervention
that is really the most
important project right now?
>> So we actually had a lot of
challenges with that So we had
several previous publications
that were published in medical
journals, and they did not
emphasize the algorithmic or
methods portions of it,
the doctors were very
interested in the outcome.
So when we said something like,
you wanna spend a lot of money
and you still want to
DST people upfront, and
still spend a lot of money on
testing people unnecessarily,
they're like that's crazy.
But, it's the result they were
interested in, right, and so
they were like it doesn't matter
if we don't know about PalmDPs.
We still care about the result.
>> I have a question for
Phoebe, I guess.
>> Yeah.
>> Based on your work that you
were talking about, how you
model fairness as a parameter.
One is you talked about the
fairness definition was whether
that can be equal in each of
the vulnerability groups.
What would be some other
fairness criteria for
the particular work?
The second point is more
of a general comment,
whoever can answer, is I think
we're now working on the area of
intersection of a lot
of different regions,
a lot of different areas and
public policy ideas,
and people how they
perceive these things.
And in terms of translating
this to a general public policy
audience, it wouldn't fly
if I were to say that as
long as you can model this
as a linear parameter,
fairness will be taken care of.
So what would be some of these
communication strategies that
would be required if
anybody has any thought,
because I think that's going
to be central going forward.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> So your first question
related to fairness.
So what other fairness
constraints may be relevant in
this context?
So that's a great question.
So I think the way I would
approach it is to go back to
the current policy and see what
attractive properties it has,
if any,
hopefully it does have some.
Where, for example,
you may have fairness across
different genders, right, or
fairness among different
racial groups, etc.
So these are things that one
would want to investigate and
definitely not lose, right, when
moving to a different policy.
So fairness really is up to
the user, to some extent,
to define based on the context,
what are some properties
that you'd be looking at.
For example, in the context of
kidney transplantation, major
issue has been that there has
been a severe organ shortages
for black people, because it
turns out that matching is not
as good between blacks and
whites, and they suffer from
ISI far more frequently than
whites due to lifestyle reasons,
and so fairness among different
races is of course critical.
Your other question related
to how do you go back and
actually explain, so explain
what it means that how you can
express fairness constraints
as linear constraints.
I think, basically, the way I
would go about it, of course,
I'm open to other suggestions,
is to highlight that any
constraints that would
basically, enforce equitable
success among different groups
of users, different groups
of homeless youth, for
example, can be taken care of.
And I think this really captured
the vast majority of partner
constraints that
one could think of.
Sorry.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Hi,
so it's real exciting
to have health and
social scientists here today,
thanks for coming.
I wondered if I could ask
a questin maybe for the three of
you, if any of you would like to
answer, Phoebe, and Monica, Azi.
So I think what we're all trying
to do in the room is find new
applications for technology to
have impact beyond research.
So actually impact in the real
world on real people.
I think that's still, in some
sense, an aspirational endeavor.
I don't think there's,
at least in my mind,
the single shining example
where someone has succeeded
dramatically in doing that.
I think one useful thing for
us to think is what are the best
examples, even more broadly
just beyond technology,
what are the best
examples of researchers,
in their home discipline,
bringing their techniques and
tools that has a direct social
impact around the world,
and I have some examples
from computer scientists.
I'd really be curious if any of
you have, either now or later,
are there examples in your home
discipline that have inspired
you, or your colleagues,
your peers going back maybe in
the distant past, are there
examples people look at where
researchers with publications
and intellectual exercises,
where that research process
led to a big social impact?
Are there things we can
think about studying?
How do we clone those successes?
Are there things on your mind?
I'm just curious.
>> Not my own projects, but
some of the work I did with my
advisor when I was
in graduate school,
was that she worked a lot in
the US with various governmental
programs like the CDC,
or two more limited and
working with programs, and since
they have interventional arms,
it was much easier to implement
policies in that sense.
So they would do will the model.
They would solve the model.
There would be interesting
technological contributions
that they could publish, but
in the end maybe the models were
simplified, and then pushed
out to these arms that could
actually use them on the ground,
and do these iteration,
which I think a lot of the work
around here with and Erik,
have also been endeavouring
to do, but that's the,
I think a good mechanism by
which we can translate this sort
of more academic stuff
into real world impact.
>> William gets the last word,
and
I think that we are beyond time,
so.
>> So I feel the question
that Shivram you asked, and
the question that was asked, you
know the comment that Bill made.
I mean these are all really
important things that we need to
discuss here.
The more science that
gets generated in this
interdisciplinary context is
neither publishable in AI
sometimes nor in say social
science, cuz it's at this
intersection where AI people
think there's not enough AI, and
the other people think there's
not enough other science.
And so, this is the struggle, I
think, for AI, for social good,
is to come up with a new venue,
where this kind of work is
encouraged and really
publishable, for example, and
I guess, with respect to this
is really a terrific question,
with respect to how to
take this research, and
I don't think we as professors,
or researchers,
are equipped really to
push this research out.
There needs to be
a different mechanism,
a social entrepreneurship
mechanism, or some other
mechanism by which this
research can get translated.
It's really difficult,
I don't think we have the right
skill set to really do that,
the right capital, etc, etc.,
and I applaud your question.
I mean,
it's exactly the right question.
>> [INAUDIBLE] Because the
students come to us [INAUDIBLE]
Give an example as to the change
[INAUDIBLE] they can use, and
you'd better train them in
[INAUDIBLE] technologies,
right, and [INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH]
>> This is question I have
stuggled all of my life and
I find that it's,
I'm being unfair, I'm not
really good for my students,
if I make them do my team
project [INAUDIBLE], but
then my students
might [INAUDIBLE].
>> [INAUDIBLE] Absolutely.
Does it work?
Just to follow-up,
I [INAUDIBLE] and
often what you see is that
they have [INAUDIBLE] but
they work with
government agencies,
[INAUDIBLE] they work with
NGOs they advise NGOs, so
they have a lot of input
going through the world.
It's behind the scenes,
you don't even know that they
advise the government, but they
do, and so I think that's a role
we can take on, but we're not
used to it in computer science,
but people are starting
to do that.
They've become involved in
other organizations and
have influence that way.
So we don't have to
do it ourselves.
>> Okay, thank you.
I think we have a coffee
break to [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]